in this short video I'm gonna show you
how to create several types of RNA seek
pipelines and how to use the different
options in these different sections that
you see on the screen after I have
already uploaded the raw fast queue
files either directly to the platform or
using a reference STL file now what
we're going to look at is what is the
logic behind different combinations and
how do I achieve specific targets with
these pipelines so my first button is
always going to be start and then I'm
gonna do the simplest thing so the
simplest thing is to take my raw reads
in raw fast queue files and use both
tied to T mapping on transcripts and
then transforming the mapping into a
gene expression table now this table is
going to have gene IDs and Aiza form IDs
from the known GTF file so whoever did
the assembly put together a file that
lists the beginning and the end and the
different variations and names of all
the possible genes and isoforms on that
genome so if i click end i am going to
have this pipeline so i'll do cancel and
now you can see the pipeline now I can
also right-click on each step and then I
will go back to the start and now let's
look at the same pipeline but with some
pre-processing options so again I can go
to trim Ematic which will reduce the
adapters PCR clean removing the
duplicates from PCR amplification go
back to bowtie to T and then our some
expression table and then I will do end
so this is another simple version the
same pipeline but with some
pre-processing steps now you can see
that after this step after I have the
are some expression table I can also
create a separate eggs on table and now
I will have two output files let's do
that again and just read the description
you have eggs on expression another file
in the
- your expression of genes and
expression of Isaac ohms okay
now also I have an option to do
differential gene expression so once I
have the table of expression I can do
other downstream analysis with the table
and so here I can use something like V
set - or edge R okay and then I will
click on end
now what if I go back all the way here
let's remove all of this and let's do a
more detailed analysis of the elements
that we have without relying on the GTF
file provided to us by the people that
assembled and annotated the genome so
what would I do
I would start again here and then I can
go to bowtie - G and then BS Exxon which
will map the exons and then I go to gtfo
just create an adjusted GTF file then i
can use bowtie - I bowtie - I will map
on junctions then I would use ISO lasso
which will create the isoform so now I
have I the forms and then I will merge
these new isoforms into the old GTF file
and then I can do bowtie - T mapping on
this new GPF and finally our some
expression table and this is a more
complex expanded pipeline that uses my
custom configuration to get a more
detailed view at various elements also
those that are not known and some are
the putative genes that could be
expressed and again I have the option to
separately look at exons and separately
do differential gene expression now
let's go back in fact we will go all the
way back to here ok and now let's start
what does top have to do so top hat or
top hat - is the same thing essentially
it does these three steps in its own way
and it's considered to be
somewhat of a gold standard so what I
can do is I can go ahead and click on
pop have to which it doesn't have a
description you notice but that's just
because it's exactly the same as pop hat
so I can do either one of those tall
count is just the newer version of top
hat and then I can go cufflinks cuff
merge bowtie PT and now I can go to our
some expression table that is if I want
to have an expression table now what if
I don't want an expression table then I
can go from cuff merge and go directly
to cuff this and then I will just get a
differential gene expression and as you
saw let me show that again we already
have the false discovery rate threshold
now if you go to transcriptomics two you
will see there a whole description of
what false covery rate is and this is
gonna be important for your cutoff for
the differentially expressed genes okay
so all the same things of course could
be done after a talk have two you can go
you can go back in fact let's go back
all the way over here and now you
understand the logic you have the step
of mapping on genome the step of
identifying exons and then mapping on
junctions creating isoforms processing
that back into the GTF file mapping on
transcripts and creating an expression
table now sometimes there is a
completely different problem at hand and
we have a non annotated genome or the
genome is not very well annotated maybe
the assembly wasn't done very well and
we're interested in using that genome
and just identifying which areas are
highly expressed so that we can try and
annotate those so what would we do we
would again start over here and then we
would go to bowtie 2g okay and now you
can see that we have an option to do
segmentation and in segmentation we're
not going to go too much into
this pipeline because it's used for very
specific cases but you can actually
select very specific areas that have a
high expression level
you will update again the GTF you will
create an expression table you will do
the segmentation on that table
and then you can use those reads and do
blast X so blast those sequences and try
to annotate now this is a very
complicated process it will require a
very specific situation so that's why
we're not really going into detail about
the segmentation and annotation points
now another thing that you will notice
here is that all of these files the
pre-processing files are essentially
going to work with a lot of your options
right here and that's very important so
that you know that for every type of
pipeline that you do you can add some of
these now what is this error correction
section the error correction section is
actually useful for poorly sequenced
files and for microarray files and
that's why it was added here now in most
cases you're not going to be using this
this is a very computationally expensive
pipeline to run and so only use it when
you know how you will analyze and
evaluate your results another section
that we didn't cover here is the data
simulation the data simulation allows
you to generate reads and tests in
different options different pipelines
using mapping the ROC curve for
different steps of the way to generate
those curves compare different methods
now we're also not going to go into how
to create a pipeline like that because
our focus was how to generate a number
of simple RNA seek pipelines that you
could use to analyze your data now in
the next section we will try to cover a
little bit more about the different
options for differential expression and
how to analyze the table that you get as
a result of these pipelines